aller en france à présent une
soixantaine de manifestations contre la
pma ce samedi à l'initiative du
collectif d'associations dont la manif
pour tous à paris vous le voyez place
vendôme pas plus d'un millier personnes
règle sanitaire oblige on se re tester
contre le projet de loi bioéthique et en
particulier contre l'ouverture à la pma
pour toutes les femmes des manifestants
qui demandent le retrait de ce projet de
loi bioéthique
ils protestent contre la pma samper et
la gpa un texte voté le 1er août en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
le projet de loi devrait être adoptée
définitivement dans les prochains mois
vous voyez les précisions sur place de
notre reporter qui cote eekhof la zone
comme à paris les horaires et les
consignes ont été respectées à la lettre
aujourd'hui pour ce rassemblement sur la
place vendôme manifestation a débuté à
15 heures tapantes et s'est terminée à
17 heures pile pas plus de 1000
personnes rassemblées ici sur la place
vendôme aux raisons du coc vide
officiellement avec de nombreuses prises
de parole tout au long de l'après midi
des membres d'associations anti ivg la
manif pour tous dont le président le
vice-président de cette manif pour tous
albéric dumont qui s'est exprimé au
micro de rtl france je crois que malgré
un contexte sanitaire exigeant malgré
une vie démocratique des graves et les
français ont répondu présent à l'appel
du collectif marche aux enfants ici
place vendôme est aussi dans 60 vivent
en france pour dire non au gouvernement
pour dire non ce n'est pas le moment de
faire passer un tel texte
on est en crise sanitaire on est en
pleine crise économique sociale et la
priorité des manuels macron c'est la bm
à son père sinon il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas dans ce gouvernement et nous
sommes là pour lui rappeler notre
position
notre détermination contre ce texte on
est bien évidemment loin du 1 million et
demi de personnes rassemblées dans toute
la france il ya sept ans mais les
membres de cette manif pour tous
comptait bien montrer qu'ils étaient bel
et bien présents pour continuer leur
combat avec de nombreux drapeaux rouges
et verts qui ont été agités tout au long
de l'après-midi par les manifestants des
drapeaux sur lesquelles on pouvait lire
liberté égalité paternité une
manifestation qui s'est donc terminée
aux alentours de 17 heures avec 60
autres manifestations qui étaient
prévues un peu partout en france